[Music]
foreign
from exactly the same thing in that
they're just defiantly I'm still the guy
I I honestly believe that Ronaldo knows
that he's he's not the same really but
he's modified his game and he's just he
works between the 18-yard box and wants
this [__] score goes it doesn't take
a good service still scored the goals
but when he did that interview with
Pierre there's a hint of like
what did you think of that uh well I
only see in the clips
I felt I felt as anger that he felt
disrespected like he felt like I've come
here I'm your top goal scorer you've put
me on 500 Grand a week because I'm the
main man you need me and then I just I
want to get this out do you really think
Ronaldo's only on 500 oh it'll be more
than that yeah yeah so so that we know
right and then in season two he's like
right ready to pick up where I left off
last time and then ten Hogs like easy
take I'll put you on the bench and then
he gives it the I'm not gonna disrespect
Ronaldo by bringing him on late in games
when they're losing the man city was it
and then sixth yeah and then he
literally tries to do that exact thing a
matter of a few weeks later I'm not
saying 10 Hogs completely to blame here
but I I see why Ronaldo's like in his
head he's like what the [__] is going on
and no player is bigger than a team I
get that but there are some players that
are like messy uh Ronaldo yeah sit down
you don't bring these players on for
three minutes yeah as a manager you know
what you're doing well and no I'm not
disrespecting ten ARG listen it's a
[__] tough situation to come into a
football club if that is in transition
you've got Ronaldo and he's played it
brilliantly and Ronaldo just had a bite
up like I see carragher he's a disgrace
he should be sacked and was he wrong yes
can I call him a disgrace when I've not
played right wing for the greatest
England manager since South Ramsey I
understand we're humans we [__] up for
people to say
he's a [__] disgrace and he should be
sacked and I and I get on really well
with Karen there's only
two years ago you had your incident and
where you could have lost your job at
Sky I could go with us yes but sorry
yeah carrier and we've all we're all
things but so I just like if I was a
pundit on the TV I would have said he's
wrong you cannot Slaughter the manager
in public like you did but I understand
frustrations I cut who am I to call
Ronaldo disgrace when some of the things
I've done in my career and all of us are
done in a career and I know they get
paid for their opinion I just think they
need to wear that
word it differently because you all
sound like [__] Hypocrites when you
are the greatest footballer ever
arguably if not at least one of them
I understand that your ego in that
moment is is to a size that you're like
look I deserve more respect than this I
think I think it's it's naive for anyone
to think Ronaldo should be cool with
that it's just a Michael Jordan of man
united here speaking of a pro
we should come on no matter we could be
Michael Jordan and if you were asked to
come on for two minutes so Ronaldo
should have come on absolutely but
you're right his ego what is contributed
for Man United in the past what kind of
stay to see us in the game that is a
disgrace you can't expect Ronaldo to
come on with two minutes to go
especially when your manager said the
week before I didn't bring him on out of
respect like I said listen I don't know
what's going on in 10 hours thing I
didn't think he wanted Ronaldo in the
football club and he's playing the he
has played a Blinder what makes me laugh
as well is that everyone's
what a great job he's doing
man united are on the up bloody bloody
blah the one point less one point less
off this season than when they were in
the previous season with solska who was
crap and got the sack but 10 hours let's
spend 250 million more by the way but 10
ARG is unbelievable
and I hope it works out for him because
man united are a big Club they've been
in so much transition they need to stick
with a manager but to say what an
unbelievable job you've done
at one point less oh I think I think
he's doing as good as he should be let's
talk about the World Cup a bit because
it's our note but as we're recording
this England are about to play Wales
later today uh we're fresh off the back
of a lackluster game against America
in that game one of the main criticisms
of Gareth Southgate was his lack of
ability to use players uh who are you
know similar to yourself in your Prime
creative fast and and there to get a
defenses and open the game up and we
just couldn't do that uh and I think
um when I'm looking at Phil Ford and sat
on the bench I'm wondering what people
are like you are thinking
Phil foden is Pep Guardiola has said he
is the best young player he's worked
with
obviously Messi was young but he was in
the first team but I'm talking about
from he's playing he's had all he's
brought him through he's brought all
these players through Barcelona B and
that and he says
foden is the best young Talent he has
ever worked with we are not letting him
go on loan because I want him around me
to have my coach and to work with de
bruyner so when you've got the greatest
manager and Coach talking about an
English Talent
like that so the way I spin it is
with mbappe
at France be on the bench
exactly would Neymar be on the bench
when you've got these special talents
and he is real special I think that man
city would beat the England team
if you put man seat at 11
and you replicated that with the England
11 I fancy Man City to beat England
quite convincingly I agree yeah
and he's one of the first names on the
team sheet for Man City he they've spent
100 million on grealish he keeps
grealish at the team he lives Sterling
out the site exactly left yeah because
Fordham kept them out the team and yet
Sterling is starting
so for me it is such a shame that we
could be talking about
obviously everyone says grealish is
probably the closest thing we've had to
a Gaza but I honestly believe that
folding is the most special player we've
had since Gaza when you see a talent
like that not being able to make the
team
every other country he would be playing
so
it does piss me off as an English fan
watching it and this is no disrespect to
Jordan Ellison because on the podcast
I've give you I've give Jordan and
Henderson loads of love and showed you
why he's in the team but you're bringing
Jordan Henderson that to me is we don't
want to lose the game rather than we
should go and beat USA and then when I
hear the the quotes after and we were in
complete control when the way John
stones and Maguire controlled the game I
thought their Midfield three dominate
our Midfield 3 the Leeds player Tyler uh
Adams we couldn't keep the ball there
just they did nothing with the ball you
know they were lumping a fuller getting
corners and they were clumsy going
forward in the tuck but they were
winning the ball back offers it rapid
pace and I felt like our midfielders and
our whole team was giving the ball up so
easily it was embarrassing actually and
that was due to a lot of ball players on
the pitch really who were and
I also feel like maybe southgate's
personality filled us through to the
players or is fear of losing because
when I watched Jude Bellingham pick a
ball up and I look at him look side to
side Look Backwards and look for the
easiest possible options and I'm like
that's not who you are I've seen you for
Dortmund you are one of the most
confident attacking young players you
know arguably up there with affording in
terms of natural talent and we're
playing so sheepishly this is one for it
so with Trent and I've been a coach and
I've heard Gary Neville and I've heard
all the pundits I've heard
Shira I've heard everyone what Trent
can't do what Trent can't do we never
Embrace what players can do
what can he do could you imagine him
against USA the other night
talking about Harry
reaches of the ball inside the Penalty
Box starved
we have got the I've never seen
technique like it since David Beckham
and this is from a right-back is
incredible going forward but all we keep
seem to do is Bash him of what he can't
do okay
if you're that worried you wire up and
you're going okay he might get us a goal
but he might lose his two goals I can
understand that against a Brazil or a
Spain but when it's USA Wales
come on get Trent on the pitch and
listen this is no knock because trippier
has had an exceptional season at new
cost I went live a first game I went to
watch as a fan was Newcastle Chelsea
just before the World Cup and Newcastle
was brilliant but and trippier were
brilliant
but Trent and this is no disrespect to
trip here when you're talking about
assists like you said he's nearly broke
every assist record there is for a
fallback already and he's what 22 23.
um he was another one I'd play I'd play
him in all these games and like you said
if we then coming to Brazil when you're
worried about vinicius Junior then
hopefully Carl Walker's fit or trip here
and you you bring them in but again we
love to tell players
what they can't do uh there's been a lot
of talk about the politics and that of
the World Cup we don't have to go into
it too heavy but obviously there's been
a lot of pundits seeing what they're
saying but then they're all out there
taking the money and you've got people
like David Beckham who got paid 150
million to promote this
um
I don't know is there any feeling from
you about whether or not you would want
to work out there or does it make you
feel any kind of way
come into my house
if I invite you around to my house you
abide by my rules
all right bye by my rule she will not be
welcome back into my house
that is as simple as that so when they
won the bid
this should have happened before the bid
all this [__] that's going on and all
this this should have been squashed
from early as soon as their name come up
club's team should have said we're not
going or we're doing this
so
now with all this country like with the
alcohol you know what this country is
you you have to respect
these people
that's just my take listen do I agree
with their beliefs no I don't but we
knew this
eight years ago whenever they got it and
now we're kicking off and it's a joke
we're not wearing armbands in that
we shouldn't be allowed to wear the
armband you know what this cup what this
country their rules
you agree to it you're here representing
well get on with it I heard from a mate
who's over there that they're in the
mall there was some loads of England
fans
and obviously get your tits out for the
lads you know that song yeah they were
singing to they were singing to All the
local women get your face out for the
lads right honestly and I'm just like is
it Banner in their thing yes but there's
a Code of Conduct you're in their
country you will get [__]
yeah you know you can't do that yeah so
the fa we want to make a stand we'll
make Harry Kane take the yellow card and
wear the open armband you know what I
mean but like I said I just think it's
all disrespectful to the country
yes we don't if you were coupling and
that was you
what would you have done would you put
it on anyway or would you have would you
have let them tell you what to do and
took the lead from the fa because I feel
like Harry kind of took instruction on
that yeah we we always get taken
instruction I can remember I don't know
if you know this story so um
when Rio found his drug test and
obviously he had his hearing to come so
he hadn't been proven uh guilty of
anything we had to play
turkey to qualify for the euro 2004.
European championships we only needed a
draw
uh England fans were banned from going
for some punishment so you could imagine
turkey hostile as [__] and Gary Neville
calls and committee together and this
one I really no seriously
I used to see Gary Neville is like
[__] a geek yeah and then like when I
looked him I thought [__] me this is
Millie Ferguson he calls this meeting
right honestly he calls this meeting
like Bex is the captain and white and
he's just like everyone sit down it was
like this is [__] unacceptable like
he hasn't even had a case and he's being
banned from England that's that's when
does that happen and he said we're not
playing while he says I'm not playing
he's my teammate man united teammate I'm
not playing
I think we should make a start and say
we're not playing
so we were like I was like [__] it yeah
yeah
I like I seriously I think at least it's
quite yeah
that's like a high school kid like any
reason yeah
[__] ambrio's my mate and I was like
yeah brilliant so like everyone so
basically we left the room and everyone
was in agreeance so Gary goes off to see
some fa people uh
the fa people were like seriously you
will get absolutely pelted by the fans
the media
you're refusing to play for your country
and we'll have to play the under 21s so
um or we call this Brooklyn yeah and he
was listen you can't call Gary and
everyone who's Bluff mate he's once he's
got beliefs like [__] a lot of people
say a lot about him but I do I do love
how he sticks to his morals I mean he
did until uh yeah
you know what we've been doing business
with them for about 20 years they're all
right
yeah
so then um
so then obviously Bex and Mike alone
must have spoke to agents all players
back to agents and they realized about
maybe like you said losing the
sponsorships and that and then that just
got me the fa we're just not having it
so the fa do take over
but that's a kraken story yeah but with
the with the armband like you said it's
like do you take one for the team if you
really all believe this
then yeah you should take one for the
team but then again
I'm again when you go into someone's
house you have to abide by their rules I
the rules are shitty but that's how they
live there like you say
how many people go to all these
countries for [__] extravagant
holidays they don't care about their
rules then if you know what I mean so
I don't know it's a tough one when it
comes to obviously uh
uh LGBT
um footballers uh I was wondering
actually on the topic of this did you
know any footballers who had their
sexuality like personally or or was that
something that you were just completely
unaware of I I had my suspicions when I
went to West Ham
um it was the German player Tommy
little Sparkle was it oh Tommy hits a
burger [__] I can't even remember his
name that's how much of a you remember
no that's how much of a shambles my
[__] time at West Ham was so loud but
um
I have my suspicions that he was gay but
I never asked him never treated him
differently and he came out a few years
later didn't he I think when he retired
ah
um and said he was gay
um I wasn't shocked it was the same as
when I did the jungle I'm a celebrity we
had that pop star George
and I was like
in my head thinking he's definitely gay
oh he didn't say nothing and then a few
a few months after the jungle he comes
out and says he's gay
um
I have gay friends I have I know gay
people
um I miss you wonder I was still sort of
waiting for a high profile player
because I just think it's the uh it it
should be so much easier to come out now
people can be brutal do you know what I
mean I think for a footballer to take
that on it's going to require some
[__] balls unfortunately uh
you think in a men's team sport I'm just
asking the question here is like say if
I was gay and I brought up into an
office
but and you said it's different in
football
we share showers we share baths we like
like I don't know I don't know so if I'm
with a gay
right I just walk around the change room
with [__] dick flopping from ankle to
ankles
yeah I wish but you know I mean you like
and then all of a sudden as a gay do I
like
I don't I I don't know do you start to
cover up a bit more do you like rather
do you mean to respect that person yeah
you don't want to make them feel
uncomfortable yeah it's just like and
there may be feeling on that side as a
gay man like I don't want to put the
boys in a position where they have to
feel a certain way about me so look I
would just leave it just to keep it to
myself but
yeah I don't know I think it's an it's a
good conversation to have and although
it is awkward and you know we're two
straight men trying to understand what
it would be like to be in that position
it's [__] difficult but you gotta
respect it and hope that one of them
does feel comfortable because then I I
think it'd be like the four minute mile
it'll happen when someone break when
Bannister broke the formula more than
everyone's starting to break well and
right and it just needs that one high
profile player do you keep in touch with
many of your old teammates I'm really
close to Jonathan Woodgate still
Jermaine genus who's doing really well
Bellamy maybe of course Bellis I'll
always be in touch with him there was a
story told about him actually recently
on uh talksport by Graham Sooners who uh
how he cut him he basically said uh he
wouldn't play for us so I took him to
the chairman so go on then say it in
then
I'm not playing he's like right you're
off no that didn't quite go like that
but that story was how do you remember
it I'll never forget this story again
when you're talking about [__] you
think Ronaldo's Drew is bad so
um
someone had told soonest that Bella said
in the change room
at the training room before he was gonna
go to train it if I'm gonna be playing
on the left or right wing I'm just gonna
throw an injury
so obviously when we've gone out to do
shape
Bellas is obviously put on one of the
wing positions
and um
and he said [__] it I'm walking in I
can't well off the pitch so he's just
she said oh I'm feeling my groin or
whatever my grind's a bit tight or
something so uh
um someone had told soon as this uh
probably [__] owl Shay given there
was a teacher no I just know that
[__] hour I'd have probably ripped
Bella's head up for saying that every
time Bellas did play then that's
guarantee goes through Allen because
yeah they were like conflicted weren't
they they worked so well together but
personality is completely different so
we didn't think nothing of it then the
squad goes up and Bellas is in the squad
and so I think the manager must have
said look you're going to be playing up
front or whatever must the condom into
it so uh we go to Arsenal we get into
the change room so usually you name the
team at the hotel doesn't even name the
two in the hotel so
I mean they're changing and he says the
change this
well this is not even think so Bellas is
[__] fuming so we play Arsenal so as
soon as [__] with his head a bit yeah
yeah if you're gonna [__] try and
[__] think so I'll never forget this so
the game finish and we're on the bus
Bellas is fuming this [__] pricking
and then ghosted on the bus you have
Skye and it goes to Jeff streeves and
he's interviewing
um souness in the tunnel so he says to
suit this he says to see
why is Craig Bellamy not playing he went
Craig Bellamy's uh reported an injury
and Jeff was like um
that's weird because um I asked Craig
and Craig said he was fit to play he
said no no he's got an injury so he's
like so Bella this is where Bella's got
a kind of power trip because he knew the
fans loved him and he knew the fans
didn't love Sooners so he fought the
fans are on east side oh he's not
[__] turnip so we're literally
sitting on the bus watching this oh I'm
not [__] having this he said he just
gets off the gets off the bus and goes
so I'm thinking what the [__]
so it goes back into the studio with
Richie keys and whoever the guest was
and uh
they have to cut one of the guests they
go sorry we've got Jeffrey's back in the
tunnel as well
thinking
I'm watching this so Michael on the bus
so mine this time
uh Graham gets on the bus do this and
Freddie ship is on the bus was like I
was fit to play it was his decision not
to play me
so I'm thinking I can't believe this so
I'm just think because I know Graham's a
[__] hard man by the way I'm thinking
when he comes back on the bus he's just
gonna get washed up
um but he didn't he gets on the bus then
Bellas
arranges I don't know if you can
remember the time he arranges for Skye
to come to his house and give us an
exclusive interview because he was
trying because he thought he had the
fans on side
and then Sooners couldn't protect him no
more and I think soon as said he refused
to play throwed in an injury and then
yeah there was no way back from button
that whole thing were on the bus and
we're watching Bellas right off the bus
and then next thing he's live on Sky
[__] it it's so childish isn't it when
you think of it it's so silly obviously
we'll mentioned Newcastle so you know
more about the Newcastle setup than I do
um how's Eddie doing for a start I mean
obviously it's going good but what are
you seeing that specifically is
impressing you about Eddie I couldn't
believe that power energy and Pace that
you play with when I was watching him
live at Chelsea
you were getting Chelsea to boot the
ball long you were going I dare you to
play the people would play and
fair play to Joe Linden because I've
been one of his biggest critics but the
energy he must have my lungs when I was
playing he can run all day but with that
power and Pace his long legs and that
yeah and he'd just go I just look at
that team and identity and I think that
Eddie's motto is something about
intensity and it's um our identity is
our intensity and you see that on the
pitch and the recruitment has been
brilliant bringing in trippier and
um but Batman's a good player isn't he
good player and Bruno is just a game
it makes me mad when I'm watching Brazil
and I see Fred play
and this is no disrespect to Fred
because he does well for
um Brazil but Bruno has been in the top
five probably players performing this
season yeah in the league easily
everything Newcastle had done I've Loved
I went there as a fan I couldn't believe
the energy it just reminded me of just
thinking they're on to something the
only
thing I worry about is that
if you have a chance to go in Champions
League and then you start to try and
sign a superstar
and this is no knock on Eddie
um
will he be able to handle the Ronaldo's
the mbappe you know I mean where they
could just like look at him and go
who the [__] are you you're not like
it's different having a Potch and I
think I would be unfair for him because
of what he's done to that club and
another one we can talk about and
everyone used to [__] Hammer Steve
Bruce so everyone's saying about this
transformation of almoran he ain't been
transformed basically when he was
playing for Benitez or
uh Steve Bruce he was basically playing
as a fallback because all you like you
stalk your wings used to do is Defender
fullback she used to defend your box and
just boot the ball
now you're on the front foot
He's Got Confidence because you're on
the front foot and you're getting him
the balls in the area where he can be
destructive there's no coincidencies
shining but how do you helped played him
like that exactly so that's where
anything but I'm just saying almarin
doesn't all of a sudden become a bad
player it was just he was in a bad setup
that did nothing for him now he's being
in a system where he can flourish
Jolin and his founder system that he can
flourish
I even you've even played with Chelsea
and you had Chris Wood
and I'm going like housier like player
from Newcastle but all right it's crazy
but everyone just fits in you had a
center off playing left back on the day
he was [__] outstanding I'm just
going yeah fair play I'm I'm loving
Newcastle and I do still think they'll
make the top four
yeah the thing about Eddie and I really
uh think you've made a good point there
with how is this going to go because
right now Eddie commands respect of that
dressing room and and there's nobody
there in in that team who's achieved a
great deal yet and I think that that's
that's a good thing for us because
everyone there's this little Underdog
feeling about us and it kind of reminds
me of Jurgen klopp when he took over at
Liverpool very similar intense style if
you look at what trippier and Elmira do
on the right side it's like Trenton Mo
Salah it's exactly the same sort of
theory uh just not as good
um but it's looking pretty good this
season you know and I feel like for
Eddie he's such an intelligent guy I
never watch an interview with him and
cringe like that was the Steve Bruce it
was hard watching his interviews it was
embarrassing as a fan to think that's
our manager whereas with him he
articulated himself well and I just hope
that we don't get someone in who
I think there's a strategy in place for
recruitment in terms of Personality like
they're like no [__] basically is
what we're looking at like first and
foremost we need people who are likable
and I feel like Bruno Just sums that up
the kid loves the area loves the fans
and you can tell yeah he's playing for
us and uh in a way like it's kind of
reminiscent of the the feeling as a fan
I had to watch in the Bobby team of like
we can be anyone on our day here you
know when we went awesome they were top
of the league and you played in that
game yeah and uh you know I remember you
jumping on Shearer shoulders after the
penalty we were top at Christmas and I
remember thinking we're fearless and
I've not felt that way
since that day like I sensed that I said
20 years from the fans I couldn't
believe the energy I was just like it's
giving me goosebumps and you're talking
a Bruno I didn't realize how actually
good he was until I watched him live
he's so good on the ball as well he does
the ugly side so well he's he's just a
player the best thing I can say about
Bruno is he's a Sir Alex Ferguson player
like he to me like I look at him I think
you can you've got the nasty side you've
got the skill like here's the complete
midfielder and uh I remember I seen him
like twice and I came back the lads on
the football show and I said I I like
he's like a SAS Fabregas level player
like he could be that level I'm not
saying he will but that was just
immediately it was just like he's when
you see him in person it's yeah
um so yeah you think top four yep that
means someone's gonna lose out we've got
City and Arsenal who looks search for
the top four so
who do you think who's the other fourth
I worry about Chelsea I really do uh I'm
gonna Cobble together again we're
talking about Eddie
and then you have that Elite world-class
player
do they kind of and I I'm so happy that
Potter got his chance hmm so happy that
we've got a chance because he deserved
it but then I'm thinking
you do not sack tutual for Graham Potter
that's just my opinion I've
spoke to people who have had
tuchel as a coach
and they've had
Potter as a coach obviously I'm not
going to name them
and they're just like it's just like you
cannot compare in what way just
knowledge of the game tactics just
the way they are
um we'll ask I'll ask it after yeah I
won't drop you off so so when when and I
I also know people who have uh had
tutual and then they've had other top
top managers in there go trust me tutual
is [__] incredible but he lost his
way at Chelsea is is there a do you
think that the players down tools and
let them down but do you think that that
could be also
the Americans are coming and have
started splashing the cast on 60 million
for full Backs from [__] Brighton and
he's going
you don't know it just seemed to me a
bit like the Scott Parker did you get an
explanation from your source of why uh
Chelsea lost their way under two Sheldon
because it doesn't make sense if you're
saying that two shuttle is you've got to
remember this is the same Chelsea that
I watched the game against Tottenham
when he went crazy after the game with
the handshake but they absolutely
pummeled up I know you can say well
that's Tottenham getting pummeled by
most teams of the big boys but
they just said teacher was on a
different planet and my thing with
Potter is I think Chelsea having
problems is he's always changing the
team it's like he's trying to keep all
these Superstars happy
all of them we've got to keep it's just
like it's impossible to name the 11. I
can name you newcastle's 11. basically
every week I can name Man City he's 11
for the big game Chelsea's I haven't got
a Clues playing
Sterling Wing back he's playing one
minute he's playing a Batman and then
the Batman's on the bench of next he
goes and he's playing this fullback then
he's black so
I listen I was so happy got his chance
but I always worried that
when you've got that world-class players
and then they're not really buying into
your beliefs do they just go yeah well
you made the paint about Eddie Howe
about can he handle those big names and
Eddie is lucky that he potentially will
have a slow build up to that and he'll
be able to very much pick his own big
names Potter he's been throwing in at
the deep end in the Shark Tank and we're
going to find out quickly if he can
handle that but then I worry that when
the transfer window happens in January
because you are doing so well does the
owners go come on we've got to give it a
go to that's what I think they're
listening to earn more because they seem
to be
we don't seem to have a strategy in
place that is anything like Chelsea's
yeah and Chelsea's is a bit crazy to me
could we talk about some of your
formatting and teammates then because
they've gone into management obviously
you've done coaching at a high level and
you've got uh Lampard Gerard you know
it's been difficult for Gerard and lamp
outside his moments as well how do you
how do you say overall how they're doing
so obviously Frank
went to Derby and everyone was saying
what a great job he did at Derby
and he came sick when they got to the
playoff final but Gary Robert got sacked
for coming fifth the season before he
obviously had his Chelsea contacts he
got Mason Mountain Loan
there he had tamori on loan I thought he
did a good job at
Derby but not the way it was being
Builders what an unbelievable job and
then obviously he's a Chelsea Legend and
Chelsea come caught calling do I think
it was a bit too early
I do
but you can't turn that down you've
always got to back yourself I had a
transfer Barn as well with him there so
that was even more tricky for him I
guess if they didn't have their transfer
embargo would reach James a plate which
made some amount of played who have come
two of their popular players because
they probably would have spent 150
million pounds is a beast they would
have probably paid 150 million for a
right back yeah so to be fair with the
cars that Frank was dealt he did an okay
job again one thing I will say I think's
a real positive about Frank he then goes
to Everton and he realizes [__] hell
I've like downgraded my tools here so um
there must be a shock to the system when
you're a class player yourself and
you're like and they've got players and
you're like they've got no goals in
their teams they defend for their lives
and they're hard to score goals again so
he has changed his identity to I like
his versatility that he's shown what
about Gerard because Gerard you got
obviously he did well with a Rangers but
he gets the big job I wonder how he
recovers from that his first big job
going bad like that the thing is though
I think on your CV is when I talked
about as a player
we always want to talk about the bad
things that they can't do rather than
the good things I think the managers
once you've got have had a success that
is on your CV that I've won the Scottish
Premier League undefeated he'll get
another job I hope he gets another job I
suppose I mean
11 out of it didn't he yeah so yeah no
it's true uh that's one thing that
annoys me especially
I don't want to bring up the color but
you see the lack of black managers but
everyone gets chances but it just seems
that we find it extremely hard look Paul
links has finally got back into
management after about a 20-year Hiatus
he talked about Lampard and
Gerard getting big big jobs Soul
Campbell had an unbelievable career
On a par with them he gets Macclesfield
do you think people
get a better opportunity just down to
their skin color even though they've had
similar careers then you're seeing that
more and more yeah
if you stereotype a black player it's
about their athleticism
Pace power
it's never about their football IQ yeah
and then with white players
it's about technique yeah if they're
talking about hurricane they speak about
them
IQ smart player so I'm thinking then
when it goes up into these executive
roles have they still got that mindset
of lack of IQ
not brains is just about power and I
don't know I've never been well there
are some positives which I think we can
focus on Patrick Vieira for example
proper job he's doing there for Crystal
Palace I'm really impressed with him
exactly like Potter and uh Carlos just
been given a job in um I can't remember
uh who's Wigan yeah sorry from Leicester
yeah so again Fan Fair Play to Brendan
Rodgers so Brendan Rodgers always from
from uh the Celtic days he got KOLO
Touré in and what he's thinking was is
that
he likes to sign a lot of African black
players
and they have a complete different
religion they have complete different
beliefs and he can't understand that so
he goes and recruits KOLO Torre genius
as a coach but someone that these
players if they've got problems they he
can say well this is Ramadan for certain
players and that and I think that is
very good management because if you've
got a team that is dominated by black
players and you've got all white staff I
don't care
who you are you're not gonna know these
players more than a black you need to be
able to relax exactly for sure so I
remember doing the article about the
Rooney Rule and I was saying I I didn't
really understand the Rooney Rule so I
just gave a great headline I don't want
a job because of the color of my skin
that was the headline and then I had so
many black players like the older
players who had been through [__] who
had finished their career trying to get
jobs they couldn't and they were like
yeah what are you doing you're killing
us and I was like well I'm being honest
I don't and they were like it's not
about that it's the Rooney Rule is that
black people have to be interviewed they
there has to be evidence to be shown
that they've been interviewed and the
fact that that's a necessity really is
terrible yeah yeah and I was like
I I'm just being out and they were like
yeah but you don't understand you're
you're realized and I'm like what the
[__] and then [__] here we are like
I'm now coaching and like I'm doing the
under 18s and 23s and I'm doing a good
job but like I'm even doing a good job
if she's under 23s and then
they signed an assistant
manager on the Thursday to come and work
with me
and then the manager of the first team
gets the sack on the Saturday so I'm the
under so in the football club you have
the first team the under 23 is under 18.
okay I'm the manager of the under 23s
they signed someone to be my assistant
so he's working under me okay
on the Thursday the manager on the first
team of them first team gets sacked on
the Saturday
I get a text from my mate saying
the guy that brought in is your
assistant is now a caretaker manager I
said [__] I swear to God I just was just
like and I'm an Ipswich Boy Bread love
the club like I you're a life oh just
like you just
it is what it is you just do you speak
to anyone at the club about how that
made you feel yeah so
um
I got a text from my assistant who is
now by the way I'm your new guffer yeah
and uh he was saying that
um he'd want me to assist him and we've
got to do a game
I was like I'm not assisting you I'm
like no I'm done like no chance I spoke
to the the people above
um
and I basically
expressed thou hurt disappointed I was
they just explained that
they've implied this guy because he's
had actual experience of being a manager
in the lower leagues
um I mean you play it in the Champions
League yeah you know you played it in
the top four premier league club at the
highest level you've literally coached
all the way through you are in the
England team with David Beckham and yet
this guy knows more than you do
apparently yeah you literally know that
club inside open it so I literally
was like I don't know if I can do this
and then they pulled up the old heart
strings didn't they and said well if you
don't want to do it for yourself and
do it for us do it for the club because
the club needs you so
yeah I assisted him for
um
a few games and yeah it was just
a shell of myself I was just going
through the motions really what mentally
you just couldn't yeah just mentally I
was just they broke me mentally broken
[__] me man yeah I didn't realize it was
that yeah yeah just like I couldn't I
was just thinking
if you can't get a chance for a couple
of games like my end goal was always to
be your style manager that's what I want
to be but after that I was just like one
and two emotionally connected to the
club
I don't want to ever be manager of the
football club and it's hard to say but
do you think
why too emotionally connected what do
you mean because because some fans may
hear you say that and go well that's
what we want we want you to love them
yeah but so
when I left the club I did a podcast and
like I was picking up my players and
like there was a player who's not
signing a contract and um
fans had been giving him stick and I'm
like
well you don't know why he's not signing
the contract like he's gone out online
scored all these guys he's come back
there's no put he sees no pathway so you
can't knock someone like because you see
in the bigger picture so I'm like
because I just love the club I just I
don't know I just feel that
yeah
is it kind of better to be a little
disconnected as manager do you think so
that you operate more in a logical yeah
so ruthless so so am I Pro license on
our Pro license got some good big
hitters on the pro license as well
it's not about what you do on the grass
it's how you manage above like how I
could have manage that situation better
how you speak to certain people and they
always say that it's not healthy like
you finish up where you go home you're
thinking of the football you have got to
have a switch off you have got to have
your family life and
um I've never been a manager but even
being the only 23 manager my misses
would be like can you just stop like
this is like eight o'clock at night or
whatever and I'm just like I just can't
I just want to be the best I just got to
give these the best opportunity to
yeah and for your mental health that's a
bit draining right because you the the
we all need that rest and that period to
recover and then to be refreshed and
give your best the next day if you're
running yourself into the ground that
can't be healthy but then I think that
when I'm on the training ground
that's when I'm alive like even when I
left to have a sabbatical I'm just like
I'm just like
I
don't know if it's because my whole life
has been around the environment of
football clubs and banter and that and
I just love my I just love my boys I
still what I thought was really touching
as well that when I left the club
all all my team they tweeted about me
and the best coach and and I I just
thought that was great Testament to how
much work and Endeavor I put into him
and listen I was a hard task master as
well because what I no seriously why I
think I was so wild was so good for them
is that I always use me as an example ah
I played for England by the time I was
20.
by the time I was 20 I had man united
wanted me I had Chelsea wanted me I
played in Newcastle with the Champions
League like
going through all these things and I
said I only had 30 capture England
uh didn't win anything in my career
always injured do you know why because
my standards as a player were [__]
so this is why I have high standards as
a coach to drive you because if your
standards drop I will [__] be on you
it's nice to see that now you've grown
so much as a person you're able to talk
to these boys and uh
to hold them accountable in a way that
you didn't hold yourself accountable and
give them what you could have done with
it must be kind of therapeutic that in a
way to be a big brother and a father
figure in a way
um let's talk about when the illness
came along
uh first noticing differences basically
what it was I had a problem with my
liver it got
it's first spotting in probably about
2002 and I was taking medication it was
everything fine I could still drink I
could still do everything
um and it was probably about 2015
because obviously when you stop playing
football I having specialists in Ipswich
I go to see
uh Mr Williams and he said that you have
this condition PSC I don't know why they
said you've got this condition you've
got this condition PSC so I was like oh
what does that mean they said he said
basically you have your liver
you have loads of tubes off your liver
and they're becoming so scarred inside
so when they become so scarred it's hard
for things to go through
so I was like
oh so I said all this medication I've
been taking in the past then
is that was I not meant to be taking it
he said well
uh
is a good case so I'm already thinking
[__] out the amount of games that
people have said I missed because I'm a
medication back in my days [__] I
have a a case against all these [__]
crap doctors who say that but obviously
he was saying you don't want to go down
that road because they can say at the
time you did have this and blah blah
blah so I was like okay
um so he said
you're gonna need a liver transplant
but
probably when you're about 70 75 and I
was like okay
like
I was okay because that seems so far
away of course so this was in about 2015
and obviously I get my Bloods monitored
every month I have scans on my liver
every six months to a year
and everything was doing all right
um he was pleased and then
it was probably I had covid I got sent
home from Ipswich because I had covid
um
so I was probably a week in bed with
covid and then it's probably about two
weeks later
um I was literally when I wake up in the
night for a piss that was like pitch
black we have like these dimming lights
in the bathroom but they're really low
but when I was pissing I was half asleep
it was like
my piss was Illuminating the whole room
I can't explain I really did not expect
this seriously it was like like you know
one of them [__] lightsaber figures I
was like
[__] me I must be dehydrated all I kept
thinking was dehydration so I didn't
really think nothing of it
and then leading up to in them two weeks
there was Lee O'Neil who was head of
Academy and he kept going to me you got
[__] yellow your eyes are yellow but
again I was like looking in the mirror
and I could see some yellow in them in
in the bottom of them and I didn't
really
didn't really pay attention but this
piss I was drinking liters and liters of
water and every time my piss was just
like this [__] I can't explain the color
what what just bright just real bright I
was just like okay then I started
getting this itchiness
like itching Sensations all over my body
uh come on full on for a day and then it
would go and then it come on it was just
like where you're constantly like you've
got [__] knits in it and like [__]
the dog's got nits or something just
like
I think what the [__] going on
so then the Takeover happens at
Newcastle and the first game's Newcastle
Tottenham so Sky getting cut in touch
with me and say do you want to do the
Newcastle game with Dave David genola so
I said yeah yeah so we're pitch-side and
then we go up to the studio
in the corner far Corner
um to watch the game and then get ready
for the half time and it was probably
about
five minutes before half time the makeup
lady comes on just to give you a spruce
up and she was like
are you all right and I was like yeah
she was like your eyes are really yellow
so I didn't think nothing of it but you
know when you see like
Jamie's face Jamie redknapp and Dave
Jones the percenter they're like looking
at me like so yeah like so I think it
started to worry me now
so um obviously the game finishes
I get back on the train
down full of [__] jordies I then turn
on my phone and I've got hundreds of
messages one from my daughter saying dad
your eyes are really yellow
um there was one from my Mrs sister
uh saying you need to go
doctors as soon as you get back
so now I'm thinking [__] out
something's definitely wrong here now so
um I thought [__] I'm not going to the
doctors Monday I'm going to the hospital
so I went to the hospital Monday
um
they transfer transfer me straight to
Anne Brooks at Cambridge and I'm in
hospital for about 12 days and I'll
never forget when the first lady she
comes in about six o'clock in the
morning I've only just woke up and she
says
I'm sorry but you need a liver
transplant
and
you know in Hollywood films when the
camera just goes zooms into your face it
was just like I thought liver I always
for liver transplant or higher
transplant means death that's just
the way I see it and I just thought
[__] she's just said I'm basically dead
and she's just left me I've got no one
here it's six o'clock in the morning did
you not explain why it was just the most
she just went
hi Karen
um so we've seen your scan and your
Bloods and
um
yeah you need a liver transplant
um I could see this is a lot for you to
digest I'll be back later and she just
went and I was just sitting there going
I'm dead honestly I've never been so
scared
in all my life like it was just
[__] like
I was mad it was just like so then
having to ring up
wife
how did you explain that to them because
it all at that point you're not clued up
at all either
so are you telling them I think I'm so
when I run a wife and I said I need a
liver transplant she was just she you
could tell she went in complete shock
and didn't what okay they not give you a
second like and I felt
so sorry for her because when I was
saying I'm going to the hospital she was
like it's just probably [__] long
covered
so then now when I say liver transplant
you have that guilt which she didn't
have to have nothing to feel guilty
about it was just their opinion that I
had long covered and then
she just because I hadn't been given any
answers she wanted the answers and she
couldn't come up the hospital because
the covered and she was getting mad why
they did you ask this and I was just
like this oh yeah yeah like she's
panicking and then you're panicking and
then I was just like and then I had to
tell my mum and the thing with me is
that
you've got to be brave for them oh yeah
because if I ring up the phone sobbing
in that they'll be like so I'm like
holding this all together like oh my God
my life is [__]
and then the next person I called out so
I was my wife and my mum and then I rung
DJ spoonie
and then I just let it all out oh
because you're making it you could
handle that with your mirror and he was
just like
he was just like
yeah it was just [__]
but then when I went to Adam Brooks the
way they handled everything
was that another hospital yeah it's the
one in Cambridge and then they really so
they've got a liver transplant team so
they have the recovery nurses
they have detergent they have the
dietitian they have the psychologists
they bring people in that they've um
who have had successful operations and
then when
they come and spoke to me that negative
mindset of I'm dead was
I'll paste this
if you know what I mean just the way
that woman explained it to me compared
to how they explained that and all the
turmoil and the gray see this Gray beard
that it was all black went into the
hospital and then doctors realized like
the weight that their their words can
carry you it was so and then like
the surgeon was so confident not in an
arrogant way just
I do this for a living it's like riding
a bike you're so young
because one of the other things you do
there they have to find out if you're a
candidate so yes you need to travel now
you have to do all the tests to see if
you're a worthy candidate so strength
tests grip tests checking your lung test
because it's a 10 hour operations they
need to know is your body going to be
able to withstand 10 hours and obviously
because I'm so young and so fit I pissed
it
but the way each and every one of them
explains it to me I was just like you
know what Bring it on I can't wait to
have this and get this done and live my
life properly now
um but that was yeah that first
couple of days from that Newcastle game
was the scariest year I've ever had to
deal with ever has it been hard to be
stuck in this period where you're
waiting well because I don't understand
the process it was very hard initially
because you have to have your phone on
24 7. and you have to give them two
numbers
um
and they will ring your phone twice if
they can't get older at the ring someone
else's phone twice and then the third
person
if you don't answer you miss your
transplant you go back to square one
that could bring that can ring at any
time most of
the day most motorbike deaths or
God forbid happened late at night so it
could be early hours in the morning when
you you get a call so you've got to have
your phone on at all time and you can't
leave an hour's and a half's radius of
um radius of Cambridge so Ipswich is
like 50 minutes from Cambridge okay so
like that's one of the reasons why I had
to leave the 20 freeze as well is that
if it's playing card if I'm out of the
radius if I'm on the bench and I get a
call I'm [__] I'm going to think so so
you're in a position where you have to
sit tight and wait on them finding a
liver yeah so that was when they said I
was due to have one in three to six
months then we get to a year and I'm
like I'm still waiting they said Kieran
look if we're being honest your blood's
just doing so well at the moment you
could be waiting another year and they
suggested we suspend you on the list so
don't mean you leave the list so all
that means is when you're suspended on
the list you can go on holiday
you can go outside the radius you can
start doing things
but when we're doing your blood every
month if your Bloods are showing signs
of deterioration we will activate you
back on the list and then like that so
in a way then
deactivating me on the list means I can
I can do more things like like I said I
went to Asia to do some World Cup games
I'm doing work on uh doing some media
bits and pieces I'm going to watch
different Cubs coaching okay uh see them
train them I've got a question because
I'm thinking if I'm you
obviously you know you've not been a
saint but you've lived a good clean life
and you told me that the highest people
on those lists in terms of the quickest
to get them are people who haven't
they're alcoholics for example
now I'm not here to slag alcoholics off
because I love a drink but
is there a bit of you just as a human
thinking these guys have done all that
damage to themselves I'm trying to live
a good life here and into use uh my body
to help these these kids on the training
ground and to just give an impact to the
community here
yeah is it frustrating that's how I felt
initially that's how I felt what the
[__] someone who abuses their body I'm
someone who's never [__] taken drugs
or anything yes I've drunk but the
problem with my liver is nothing to do
with alcohol nothing it's just a
condition I got I was [__] fuming at
the system when I spoke to the team
again they're brilliant
alcoholic alcoholics
is a disease it's an illness so my
illness alcohol to them is their illness
they most of these alcoholics need
alcohol to function properly
on a mental health level yeah like I
said when with the Gary with the Gary
speed when he committed suicide I was
furious with how can you leave two kids
but then when I start to do the research
it's an actual illness
if you know what I mean so I can't then
be a hypocrite because I know that they
don't want to be an alcohol this is the
way they function my only
concern is is that
when they get the new liver
they're still alcoholics do they become
an old yeah well they are and we've seen
that with George Betts George best got a
new liver and then destroyed himself so
that's that's the only thing that would
be really disappointing but listen if
they've got weeks to live
and they have an illness I think that
they should be
top of the list that's just the way I
see it though and like you said when I
do start to
deteriorate
we've drawn this and they can't get rid
of the jaundice I think I will have my
operation so okay I really appreciate
you telling us about that man because
that was fascinating Ivan Tony uh it's
been done for gambling uh it's not the
first time I'm sure it won't be the last
I remember you were a part of the the
generation where I guess it was cods on
the bus betting this up and the other uh
what's your thoughts on it the lad's
looking like he's gonna miss he's
probably going to be banned for a while
which is a real shame because he's a
quality footballer
do you think it's right that they ban
footballers for gambling
I always used to believe that if you bet
on a match that you are playing and you
can affect the outcome then you
shouldn't bet if he wants to bet on
the Newcastle versus Chelsea for
instance the other day I don't see
what's wrong with that
um by the laws and I looked into this
apparently the idea is is that you might
know those guys Oh you mean so so he may
text to go yeah so you just do a
handball for us and this match by any
chance like that's the that's the way
they're looking at it but I mean I
personally I think I'm in the same boat
as you I think as long as you're not in
the game I don't think it should be that
big of a deal I remember Michael Chopper
is a young lady at Newcastle who had
serious gamma problems and had Heavies
wanting to break his kneecaps and all
sorts Jesus and I can remember we had a
big card school but we were on Big Dome
this is an 18 year old kid on probably
300 and he used to try and get involved
in card schools and then
either you mean at Newcastle yeah
what kind of money are we talking about
because people will be interested in
that for sure so we're doing used to
bring like a couple of bags of cash uh
just to play at hotels a good one was uh
Craig Bellamy and long Robert so we were
playing free card they basically put all
the cash in and it's like
by this time it's like 500 500 over 500
over 500 the cash was already in so
Bella's was like I owe 500. I have 500.
I have 500. so balance has like looked
at me and gone can I raise it more of
course you can I'll go a ground and then
Robert's going I'll go again I'll go go
and they're gone forever right how much
money do you think was in there by the
end about
50 to 60 Grand easily so as this was
going on I'm going Craig can I have a
look at your cards I've looked at crazy
he's got free threes it's like cannot be
beat uh-huh cannot be beat so I'm
thinking what the [__] so I'll never
forget this so they're going back and
forth and then Craig does you helps you
Martin just says you know what I'll see
you and Craig goes I got free free and
then Lauren goes to take the Jacks I
mean takes all the cash
Craig's like we're all going what are
you doing and he's like in France free
Jacks beats free freeze we're like no no
no you're in England he was like I don't
pay
and by the way Lauren Robert was a hard
bastard really I swear to God don't [__]
with Lauren Robert I mean he had some uh
good kicks on him he had a [__] fight
of Andy Griffith in the draining ground
once and that was just like oh no Griff
just went straight up to him and
he didn't even Flinch and honestly I was
just like repair mate what happened
Robert started to rag him on the floor
and get on top of him and then everyone
obviously all right but to take a he
didn't expect the punch it was just a
clean whack and he just like whatever
yeah and Griff Griff was a [__] mad
[__] as well yeah he's the one who
scored the goal against the aventus
right yeah yeah yeah so uh yeah and then
and like everyone's just like oh my God
you've got to pay Chopper I was saying I
had a bookie and um he'd ring me up and
say can you put 50 Grand on like
Barcelona to be winning at half time and
full time and it gets him like 60 Grand
back
so I'm thinking
I don't think he's got 50 anyway I'm
like all right I'll put it on
then they'll lose so he's like 50 Grand
down I'm like I felt sorry for him
because he wanted to do it the following
night with Real Madrid
and it was draw half time full time and
he would have won these money back kind
of thing cleared the debt and I said
chops I'm not putting that bet on for
you I don't think you've got a hundred
grand
and you yes you got potentially to earn
it but you can't be gambling like this
and um what made it worse this round we
did did draw I mean did win at half time
and full time and you know when you're
thinking oh the poor [__] are you
sitting there watching just something
if you just put the [__] bet on so
the next day I go to Owl and say ow I
think chops has got a problem he said
I'm gonna it's all right if I tell
Freddie Shepherd I said yeah because
like I don't know what he's on but 50
Grand losing 50 Grand when you're on 50
Grand a week is heartbreaking so
if you're on [__] 500 quid like
whatever if he has to pay me back for
those who don't know Michael Trump I was
seeing as very much a young star in the
making a Newcastle they they had High
Hopes from to go on and become a first
team regulator and they did often
compare him to Shira which obviously is
is you know comparing anyone to him is
silly but
his future was supposed to be very
bright and it never like God bless him
it never happened for him in that way he
did have a decent career the stories of
his gambling and [__] people turning
up to kill him and he used to have to go
into his bedroom and Bolt the put chairs
up against the door sleep with knives
under his bed because he was just scared
that people were going to come and just
[__] annihilate him at any time no
wonder he didn't fulfill his potential
as well because he's probably wrecked
with dreads that's what I mean like like
with the Ivan Tony situation and the
betting
[__] gambling can turn into an
illness that's all I'd say you know my
one problem with it is
uh
uh I think a lot of things can be an
illness
alcohol cheeseburgers gambling
I I think the way people are about
gambling like the way Paul Merson goes
on about and I appreciate Paul Merson
had a big problem with it and he's not
wanting that to happen to other people
but
don't try and ruin my fun I I yeah yeah
you know like just because you can't
stop eating cheeseburgers doesn't mean
we should close down all the McDonald's
you know what I mean and it's the way
they talk about it I feel like
um those who have self-restraint get
[__] over and yeah I just think um if
I've been torn it in control himself and
he's not actually betting in games that
he's playing in I don't think it should
be that that's that big of a deal uh but
we'll find out uh it's a shame he lost
out on the World Cup I think that he did
a major role in him not going
you know Gareth Southgate he's Mr Clean
and he's not going to want that lucky
Gary Neville's not in Squad then because
it's a guy innocent yeah
right yeah no one would have been going
to the World Cup well thanks for your
time today no problem I appreciate it
it's Kieran dire once again on the true
Geordie podcast absolute Legend gent of
a man and he played for Newcastle so
he's all right thanks for coming on bro
no problem cheers